qui celui là qui tu vas nous là tu vas
nous oui
félix leclerc briant qui s'est pas vu la
barboteuse là c'est le grand professeur
connaissez pas moi enfin vous connaissez
colis slalom jérémy menez relâche mais
qu'est ce que vous me dites là ça mais
oui mais je reconnais dans les
plantations
alors messieurs permettez vous êtes bien
le médecin chef et le directeur général
du centre de dépistage immédiate et
d'intervention minutes
oui j'ai en effet cet honneur jérémie
janot mais berlin mais ça sert à quoi ce
centre professeurs et bien son titre et
on y revient
oui mais si c'est destiné à quel genre
de malade
eh bien laissez les citer aux malades
qui se porte bien et au mal un don
quichotte je sais c'est un peu paradoxal
comme ça n'est ce pas ouais mais
j'insiste et je répète aux malades qui
se porte bien mais qui sont des soins le
rituel suffisamment évolué pour se
rendre compte que dans notre époque
insolite d'hypertension d'hypertension
général n'est ce pas et de comment
dirais-je 2
ce ratage survoltage cézanne survoltage
universel et il est tout bonnement
impensable et techniquement anormal
qu'un être équilibrée puisse jouir d'une
santé normale à bord vous saisissez
alors comme un huissier oui oui oui mais
alors comment que voulait traiter les
malades pendant que vous les traité de
tous les noms comme il le mérite mais
enfin le plus souvent en rapport n'est
ce pas avec le casting je vous avais dit
pas très bon orateur géorgien désirez un
client pour vous ça tombe à pic
vous avez donc tout de suite pouvoir
vous rendre compte par vous permettez
un jour fait son entrée ça y est les
toubibs et partons silva tampa bay
comment et pardon si je m'attends fait
parler oui vous vous trompez pas mon ami
mais non on n'a nullement ski français
devrait approcher n'ayez pas peur la
science est à votre service
le voyeur de 2 qu'est ce qui ne va pas
mais tout va bien
ouais je me porte comme le
pont-à-mousson avait oui c'est justement
pourquoi je suis venu vous trouvez
encore fait fort bien fait voir combien
vous avez parfaitement bien fait mais
oui c'est parfait c'est très bien c'est
un cas typiquement vous savez
symptomatique justement là comme tout
athlète très bien mais voyons alors mon
ami qu'est ce que nous vous faisons
comme opération appendicite vésicule
biliaire la parata les amygdales
trois statistiques pas mis tous aiment
je suis pas fixé les pas de préférence
au groupe
oui quand alors voyant quelques petits
renseignements d'abord d'ordre
administratif
votre nom ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance bon voyons
mais marié célibataire ni l'un ni
l'autre
alors qu'est ce que vous devez assurer
sociale
vous avez encore vos parents ah non je
les ai perdus vous avez perdu dans
quelles conditions et bien bêtement ah
oui oui dans la foule à la foire du
trône vous avez fait une déclaration de
perte à l'état civil
ah oui ils m'ont donné un certificat
d'orphelins provisoire alors vous êtes
parfaitement en règle
vivez voyeur mais par contre j'ai deux
frères haye fois vous avez encore de la
famille jamais deux frères mais c'est
une vous avez raison de le dire parce
qu'ils étaient extrêmement important
pour le diagnostic et tout ce qui en
découle
je pensais aussi que ça vous intéresse
pas et que je vous dise que j'ai deux
frères sont en fait que j'avais oublié
d'où le manga alors qu'est-ce qu'il
forme de fraise à à évin il y en a qui
est clerc de notaire à montluçon
ouais et puis l'on tait clair de lune à
maubeuge
à part ça vous n'avez aucune
rouler comme un jeu qui s'éclaire puis
c'est pas forcément bien sûr bien
attendez vous n'avez aucune autre
réalité particulière non non non bon bon
et ben alors nous allons examiner sa
d'un petit peu plus près
là les notes sont suffisantes devant
merci wen
alors bon voyez un petit peu ça non
voilà ouvre la bouche fait à je peux pas
pardon je ne peux pas faire à vous ne
pourrez pas pkoi pas verra je ne peux
pas faire ah tiens c'est curieux ça
alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire au
jeu peut faire aïe
oui oui oui c'est ça mais je peux pas
faire à l'essai congénitale non c'est
quand j'ai trop bu oui je comprends
alors de donner matière via une
serviette
alors est ce qu aurait bien là fort
expiré inspiré de la forme encore par
coeur et vous savez ce que vous voulez
vous bien sur wii la fuite 33 3 33 ça je
peux pas car dont je peux pas dire 33 33
c'est de plus en plus curieux alors
qu'est ce qui fait dire aux jeux puis
sur 12 24 48 35 39 41 92 81 10 815
l'inflation et de la flambée d'inflation
oui c'est une forme d'une émission
arithmétique voilà c'est ça oui oui vous
savez c'est assez c'est assez rare
d'ailleurs oui mais généralement ça
n'arrive que quand ça se produit
eh bien je voyais un petit peu tourné
vous fait quoi
mais j'avais fait l'aérophagie à non
mais remarquez ça m'aurait bien plu
ah oui oui ça c'est pas les moyens
ac revient cher au 15 juillet forest
liné niveau bien supérieur au niveau
c'est ça non mon coeur est ici ses
boutons là il ya longtemps que le
meilleur depuis que j'ai acheté le
costume de combien de temps on va ça
fera deux ans orange et dites moi ça me
va comme j'te parle quand j'ai trop
manger ça me sert là vous sert à quoi
ça ne m'étonne pas mon ami vous faites
un eczéma du filet oui oui oui à forme
éruptive et probablement la suite d'une
intoxication vestimentaire donc il
convient de décès d'origine rayons on va
vous faire une radio matteau même si ces
mecs te tuer je passe à la radio voilà
c'est ça m'était nous n'avons jamais
réalisé à mon avis une fillette ne mange
pas devenu plus rare a bien tiré
l'agrafé mais voilà célébrer merci m oui
beaucoup de bruit comme ça eh bien eh
ben c'est bien ce que je pensais et bien
de mon ami il était temps qu'est ce que
j'ai et ben vous faites une infection de
la poche revolver mon ami mort vous
arranger ça s'est engagé tout mais non
ne vous en faites pas mais les weir pas
une semaine à perdre on a les boules
et là mais je crois bien décontracté
vous bien des stars oui la lcd vous
allez laisser penser au bras c'est ça
les saint albanais pendrait d'honneur
c'est sa part fait là bien souple un
rapide ou bien comme ça c'est parfait
bon c'est parfait ouais bien bon mais
quand merci oui il s'agit sont ils oui
bonjour merci bien moooh la calotte
voilà merci bombesque basque à la mascc
danser tout ce qui vous avec des basses
je suis j'ai pas le temps d'attendre la
mi carême pour le pour le pôle pour le
père est allé au 106 banques s'en
passera bon alors anesthésie qu'est ce
qu'on lui fait origan partiel pas totale
chypre l'avant de hilton alors on va
dormir et à l'abattre extérieur
ouais j'ai fait elle préparait lui a
traduit je voyais en deux les yeux mais
les a jamais souri aux légumes
l épaisseur vraiment urgence weibel
merci j'ai en moi j'ai beau aimer à
grande loi type il a grandi à
l'environnement bien sûr alors c'est ça
merci aux litiges aux ciseaux c'est la
diversité de commandes non pas ça voilà
c'est ça le tranchant pascal que la mort
est gelé tous et attendait la venue de
seconde
tenez prenez ça quelques pinces à linge
attendez attendez attendez faut d'abord
+16 qu'il faut débrouiller
on a alors 8 buts les passes et par des
pinces idol ensuite il s'agit d'un bon
voilà alors maintenant attention hein
il va falloir voilà l'attendait à commet
une faute des râteaux me fait le poids
face à tommy oui j'ai oublié de dire du
donneur si la fin d'opération c'était
extrêmement d'urgence et la femme sara
de ville et une opération de la page
mais ça olala difficile ce sont les
films qui sacrifie loyer vous attendez
voir combien d'heures que je l'attendais
vous permettez d'abord que je regarde
exactement ce qui se passe voyez le
gonflement
oui bah gonflement la voyez ce
gonflement caractéristiques de la poche
les bébés espoirs avec comment dirais-je
en formation continue ce de toute la
région
intéressant de intéressant la partie du
grand chalon intéressante moyen fessier
de transfert faciale atteint et le
triceps rural avec a fait avec oedème de
la boutonnière garder la pierre aux
jeunes mères ayant entraîné un
affaissement de la patte de soutien ah
oui mais en l'occurrence un affaissement
ça me paraît normal de taxer le moral
bien entendu tout n'est ce pas de
congestion des défilés fille le vent
d'espoir avec de l'altération des points
de couture
voyez vous j'ai faim de couture sont
absolument altérée par mortification n'y
a pas que d'ailleurs parce que l'intérêt
comment il n'ya pas qu'eux qui sont
altérées on ira boire un coup de canon
et participa mortification tout ça
voyous et la 3d comme c'est la
mortification des tissus sous-cutanés
genre c'est pourquoi ne pas dès qu une
fois que sarah turine mois là et vous
voilà alors allons-y
voilà un film où ils sont complètement
conduire et paul bien pour moi les
coupes trophées ronald cocktail
sectionné la lazio neige il faut
financer ça changeait de fil je met le
clignotant
il n'ya pas de quoi rire vous savez ça
quitte à perdre
attention changement de section merci
bon eh ben voilà ça commence à se
dégager
attendez coup la voilà maintenant passer
mois de vide poches en vendant l'un des
fils de fer pour le fait de faire une
ligature la faune du passage aux foules
comme au long du clip issu il est bien
sûr ça y est ça va être stoppée voilà
donc en tirer dessus de faire maintenant
c'est stop c'est parti voilà à pouvoir
dégager maintenant on en rêvait pas mal
à vous pouvez enlever l'épave
maintenant oui vous il ya plus de
l'hémorragie et arrêter ça donnez moi de
faire le vide prochaine des mois c'est
royal complètement t'affecter on
l'espère comme cents élèves s'étaient
pressés d ailleurs
vous savez y revient de loin
malheureusement elle allait dans ses
moyens ou encore un petit coup d'oeil
et voilà ça y est là il ya encore
quelque chose me dit pas ça voilà c'est
fini
au niveau tout ça il vient dès
maintenant si tu as fait et bien voilà
l'opération est terminée
alors même si c'est n'est que mon avis
je vous laisse le soin de leur coup
droit d'accord question lui fait comme
futur bas comme d'habitude soudure
autogène aller tout de suite après
n'oubliez pas de de le passer à la
patrouille à celle tekiano valet d'épée
nous donner un bon coup de faire pour
éviter tout des formations postérieur
d'accord l'exploit
laissez moi faire oui ça va mieux
pendant qu'ils pensent également par
précaution météo quand même pendant 48
heures en hibernation a investi en
favori fiq d'accord je compte sur vos
entendu ces parfaites jeu sera fait
monsieur le professeur molesté quand un
n'aurez qu'à les bombes dans la monnaie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]